mein kollege peter wilke hat den ganzen
tag die rund 80 demonstrationen in
berlin begleitet er ist mir jetzt
zugeschaltet peter wir wollen vor allem
über die demonstration auf der straße
des 17 juni sprechen was spielt sich
jetzt dort gerade ab patricia wir stehen
direkt vor der bühne hier auf der straße
des 17 juni wo die organisation
querdenken 711 heute zum protest
aufgerufen hat jetzt in den letzten
minuten ist es hier ein bisschen lauter
geworden die polizei ist nämlich auf die
bühne getreten hat zuerst die person auf
der bühne dazu aufgefordert die bühne zu
verlassen und dieser aufforderung nicht
folge geleistet haben ist die polizei
dann dazu übergegangen die person von
der bühne zu tragen die außerdem baut
sich die polizei in schwerer montur dort
vorne vor der bühne auffordert die
demonstranten hier immer wieder zu auf
den ort verlassen weil die kundgebung
aufgelöst wurde die personen wollen der
aufforderung aber nicht folge leisten
sie schreibt skandieren wir bleiben hier
wir bleiben hier und wollen eben hier
bleiben können saß auch eine ganze menge
der menschen ja und jetzt muss man
schauen wie es weitergeht wahrscheinlich
wären die person nicht von alleine hier
weggehen wird die polizei auch alle
personen hier vor ort wegtragen ja auf
der bühne wurde ja auch genau das
gefordert gegen das die demonstranten
sind nämlich abstand halten und eine
maske tragen ist denn überhaupt
irgendjemand diesen forderungen der
polizei nachgekommen
nein auf gar keinen fall also auf der
bühne von den veranstaltern runde noch
mehr
haltet abstand halten abstand von der
maske wurde da gar nichts gesagt und
trotzdem wurde sich da nicht dran
gehalten man hat so ein bisschen
versucht in abständen zahlen aber
wirklich ernst nehmen war das nicht und
maske auf gar keinen fall wenn wir als
reporter team auf zu vielen
demonstranten kam und eine maske auf
hatten wurde zu uns gesagt die maske ab
sie ging mit maske absolutes nicht mit
euch also hier absolute anti-haltung
gegenüber der maske rund 1500 beamte
sind ja heute in berlin im einsatz wie
ist deine einschätzung wie fühlt sich
die stimmung an wie wird es dort jetzt
weitergehen ja die stimmung war den
ganzen tag über eigentlich absolut
frieden ist menschen begannen halt unter
den linden hier durch die stadt zu
ziehen und dabei auch nicht besonders
viel polizei für die zeit auch keine
helme oder sonstige montur an und
begleitet die demonstration eigentlich
nur gilt den weg frei jetzt in den
letzten minuten wird sie ein bisschen
lauter ein bisschen aggressiver die
polizei fordert halt immer wieder dazu
auf die menschen wollen diese erfolge
nicht leisten lassen skandieren zurück
und es letztlich ein bisschen mehr auf
in den letzten minuten wie es jetzt
weitergeht müssen wir halt in den
nächsten minuten schauen ein paar
demonstranten sind auch nachdem die
polizei die bühne geräumt hat in diese
richtung richtung reichstag gelaufen und
stürmen dort jetzt die reichstagswiese
direkt vor dem reichstag
und da sind dann auch entsprechend viele
polizeikräfte hinterher gerückt im
vorfeld haben ja auch mehrere neonazi
organisationen dazu aufgerufen an dieser
demonstration teilzunehmen was konntest
du da beobachten heute ja das konnten
wir tatsächlich aufgehoben ist waren
berühmte personen der neonazi szene auch
teil dieser demonstration
zwar haben die demonstranten während sie
durch die stadt liefen immer auch
alibimäßig gerufen nazis raus nazis raus
jedoch war nicht zu übersehen dass auch
rechtsextreme und hat zumindest teile
dieser demonstration waren es waren
reichsbahn zu sehen ich habe auch gehört
wer deutschland nicht liebt muss
deutschland verlassen also das war auch
teil dieser demonstration und das ist
nicht zu übersehen
peter vielen dank für deine
einschätzungen so weit